[Musique]
mais tu es aujourd'hui dans le rhône
pour voir des entreprises notamment
engagé dans la transition on a vu une
entreprise qui permettait de vendre du
matériel informatique reconditionnés une
entreprise qui a doublé son chiffre
d'affaires en très peu de temps qui
atteint maintenant un volume très
important
[Musique]
le reconditionner c'est quelque chose
qui est pas du tout appréhendé dans la
loi du coup on est soit un flou
juridique soit beaucoup de rigueur
rotation c'est assez intéressant d'avoir
reçu les sénateurs aujourd'hui parce que
on s'appelle et sensibilise sur le fait
d'intégrer un peu ce sujet est un peu
nouveau sur le reconditionner et d'y
réfléchir à chaque fois qu'ils ont une
loi de dire dans quelle case on va
mettre leurs conditions
et puis on a vu aussi dans l'entreprise
une collaboration entre la série
médicale fabriquer du ciment à partir de
matières pollué et donc ils garantissent
une filière de 100 % de matières polluer
transformer en en ciment est endetté
nous accueillons ici des terres qui sont
des nids nerthe
et ensuite notre objectif c'est de
préparer ces matériaux vont pouvoir les
valoriser dans les cimenteries du groupe
vicat
la dépollution des terres lui est pour
moi une découverte il ya vraiment une
idée à creuser pour voir comment on peut
remettre à la culture ces surfaces en
s'occupant que l'urbanisme clignotent
sur la partie agricole
là on a l'occasion justement de remettre
en culture des terres qui était de
signer plus à des l'élevage et puis
pourquoi pas selon la compensation
retrouver les dents creuses à
l'intérieur des villages où on ne peut
pas vraiment cultiver
[Musique]